es muy común encontrar fotos de
profesores combatientes y alumnos que
luchan en primera fila de la guerra en
los centros educativos ucranianos sagan
profesora de universidad no puede evitar
emocionarse al recordarlos pero cuando
escuchas las alarmas o recibes mensajes
de voz de tus estudiantes que están
luchando no puedo escucharlos son
nuestros niños los que están luchando
las clases siguen online en las regiones
más cercanas al frente y los territorios
ocupados la pandemia ya puso a prueba la
resiliencia del sistema pero la guerra
amenaza con dejar por el camino a muchos
estudiantes que lo han perdido todo
hay cambios hemos reducido el temario
ahora enseñamos menos y tratamos de
preocuparnos por la situación de los
estudiantes en cuanto a los diplomas
hemos reducido el volumen de contenido
para obtener el diploma antes eran 70 a
90 páginas ahora son 25-30 páginas
450 escuelas están en territorio ocupado
y más de 1000 centros como este en
kharkiv han sido completamente
destrozados aún así la educación en este
país no se para hay más de 12.000
centros que ofrecen distintos tipos de
enseñanza online presencial e incluso a
distancia nasal lleva desde febrero con
clases online
no es lo mismo admite echa de menos
poder disfrutar de la vida estudiantil y
del bullicio de la universidad
perdí muchas cosas perdí mi vida de
estudiante y la oportunidad de
comunicarme con mis amigos y compañeros
de clase
la seguridad preocupa mucho a las
familias de niños en edad escolar daría
tm por lo que le pueda ocurrir a su hijo
timur
por supuesto que esto es una
preocupación me preocupa enviar a mi
hijo a la educación presencial aunque en
términos de conocimiento estudia mejor
en la escuela porque la educación
presencial es mejor
sin una decisión definitiva sobre qué
centro se abrirán sus puertas el próximo
curso ucrania sigue manteniendo a flote
su sistema educativo un objetivo
esencial para el futuro de este país